oh my god we have an exclusive okay okay
let's see what do we what do you have
here what do we have on the line he's on
the line Elijah the guy who got punched
no no the guy filmed the guy oh okay
let's see it from up front the name is
who is calling in right now
Elijah Schaefer Elijah are you there sir
yeah I can hear you so um tell us what
happened Elijah
all right so currently the situation and
the police have lost control in Dallas
our militia are coming in in words
actually have absolutely no ability to
defend themselves federal agents have
come in in unmarked cars and doing
investigations coming into the city I'm
in the car right now there were shots
fired we saw the man who's defending his
store they'd stone him I can't get over
this stone now Elijah one second are you
a passenger are you driving because I
don't want you to be I don't want to be
okay all right hello and you know what
I'm not gonna lie I I first thought this
is gonna be a bit with just someone from
our crew so I wasn't action the line so
Elijah yes please take a breath whatever
you have to do here but stay safe and
yeah it can continue with your
information I appreciate you calling in
all right yeah so okay so the federal
you were telling us about the federal
agent sorry I missed some of it you cut
out a little bit explain it to us again
exactly what it was that you've seen and
I've never seen anything like this it is
one step away from a war zone yeah I I
between what I've seen in Somalia and
Aleppo this was no different there were
explosives police were doing drive-by
pepper bullet and rubber bullet just gun
shots to disperse crowds police were at
desperation and they broke into banks
they are breaking in there destroying
into ATMs into bars into the American
Airlines Center FBI is on the ground
they're using drones if it's to the
point where they had to shut down the
city and they're just lost
roll and there's cleanup every man for
himself and in which city is this
Schaefer this is in Dallas it is it
because I'll tell you what we've been
watching CNN now for four and a half
hours if I'm not mistaken I don't think
if showing Dallas one not one not once
so they've talked about how most of
these protests are peaceful and they've
never mentioned Dallas and they've sort
of pointed to Los Angeles and DC as
exceptions to the rule would you say
that Dallas was a protest that started
off with the intent of being peaceful
and it sort of got out of control or how
do you think people came into this
within 15 minutes they broke into the
tobacco shop which was by the way run by
black people
no self living but yes yes
they started looting it and started
throwing bottles and within 15 minutes
they were going let's go this way they
were telling people where where they
should go to break stuff just start
getting it started and within 25 minutes
they had already broken slowly into a
CVS started looting the CBS cheering and
so it was peaceful for approximately 14
minutes and 59 seconds 14 minutes and 59
seconds that is unbelievable specificity
um so if no I mean I mean like that's
yeah I'm like unlike at CNN they go well
for it was mostly peaceful for about
three hours right you know but you don't
want to see any of that let me ask you
this how did you so you you that was
your footage that we saw earlier of the
man who was beaten into a pulp yeah
absolutely obvious people have guns
Dallas this man was in a straight-up
knife fight but what I was saying is
they they stoned him even like medieval
picked up rocks and dropped him on his
head they they stoned a man on the
streets of Dallas and I I can I've gone
to maybe thirty of these in the last
you're alone and I'm shocked it's gonna
ask you a question because someone had
taught and I don't have any of this
verified so I am going on your word here
and obviously a trusting that you're
giving me an accurate account and I
believe you are did that man have a
sword is that what someone told me the
man who was beaten up the heat did he
charge them with a sword or how did that
happen yeah he was in front of the store
guard and he seemed to be guarding the
store right and protesters don't be
sorry to say that at all that's as this
is if it was fourteen minutes of non
rioting followed by the entire evening
of rioting you know I think at that
point it's it's fair so I'll take the
heat I would say rioters yeah go ahead I
I would say he was sort of defending
himself he's like but he screamed and he
ran kind of like started like cocky him
and then they grabbed his sword started
kicking him hitting him on the head with
state court and stuck him on the street
until he was slumped over unresponsive
people were laughing saying to let him
just let him die what but and they were
laughing hold the back of his head but
rumor is he died I don't know I can't
confirm it I'm still trying to figure it
out but I can tell you that he was
definitely close I think well I think we
saw some footage afterwards yes he
wasn't he did not die I don't think he's
died yet so on Twitter there another
question yeah there's there's some
reports on Twitter that say that he's
he's being tended to that he's been
taken to a hospital there's also and I
don't know if you can confirm this for
us or not but there's a report that he
stabbed somebody immediately prior to
that scene where he's running around and
you can see him go after a kid with a
skateboard
did you see anything no no no okay yeah
no police call and I had to see what a
guide you get hot on his hand okay like
like yeah but it wasn't nobody was like
legitimately stuff my to go round about
40 people and and I had to confer with
them that was not and they were not
stabbed because the police want to know
who was injured besides the gash there
was nobody else here it's good okay
alright okay and and you're you're
leaving the probe you're leaving the
riot now right correct you're getting
somewhere safe because it seems like
it's getting out of hand there in Dallas
yeah to be honest you know I was a I've
been up in Portland I've been up in DC
been in New York everywhere where these
events are going on and this is not a
police state this is not a race war this
is not about police brutality
this is not about racial inequality this
is a civil war going on cultural Marxist
class warfare the writer said let's
throw this direction watch were the rich
people in and it's last night there were
organizers in Dallas beautiful people
two pallets of ribs
yeah I posted about this they were
organizing people where to go how to
destroy things
tonight was people were emboldened by
the lack of police intervention and it's
scary to watch police in the United
States SWAT members sweet strippers the
FBI whole control thing in their own
City and tonight Dallas is more than its
I say it's all of America's yeah really
is scary because like I said we've sort
of been I don't want to say duped but
we've been watching CNN and having our
researcher bring in information from
Twitter to contrast it and only now CNN
because everything is ablaze I mean I
don't think that there's a place in any
of these cities where they can point a
camera and there won't be violence but
they haven't talked about Dallas at all
they've mainly been focusing and I think
I don't know what's up right now like
Washington Washington Washington Los
Angeles let me ask you first off where
can people find you and support you
because it's obviously you do a lot of
the citizen journalism where should
go to keep following your work yeah
subscribe the offensive or find you on
place to feed on slightly offensive as
well but you can get a lot of that
content right now on side offensive on
YouTube
or you can also find me on Twitter for
live updates and all the clips at Elijah
Shaffer okay oh I think you froze there
for a second did we look I'm sorry we
lost you for a second sorry continue we
heard sorry we heard at Elijah Shaffer
and then you froze if we could just
finish that cuz I want to make sure you
get it in there ya se har on Twitter but
also just make sure you got to go
subscribe to that YouTube channel we
have about a hundred protest videos and
there's on this full coverage completely
synopsis we all unedited uncut footage
is gonna air on Monday
just like the offenses okay absolutely
and I appreciate you doing the work that
Don Lemon isn't doing does anyone else
here I want to just make sure that if
anyone in this room has some questions
because you know this I thought I
thought I thought this is gonna be a bit
yeah some with a mustache in a kiddie
pool with alligators but that's next
week does anyone have any questions
there's want to make sure I'm not
missing anything
no okay alright well mr. Schaefer I know
I know you guys would just make sure you
know eyes on the road here and and stay
safe and keep us updated man we really
do appreciate it and hopefully you know
what I will say this I'll be a consumer
and that I want to see as much unedited
footage as humanly possible because yes
even if someone all of us work in this
here we do this for a living and it's
tough it really is like drinking from a
firehose and so we know that we can't
count on places like CNN and frankly Fox
News in a lot of ways because most of it
is just editorializing and I say this
the irony's not lost on me then I'm an
entertainer I editorialize but I do need
to rely on people who are hopefully
providing accurate information and it's
becoming more more difficult so mr.
Schaefer uh thank you so much brother
and please do be safe keep us posted in
the country - yeah awesome thank you
guys
yeah absolutely just make sure he's you
know does he's not the guy laughs and
then way to go rob the rest of Dallas
and that's how the protest ended the
night of the riot I should say oh my god
does it seem like it's still going yeah
that was one thing when is it is it
under control at all or the protest was
like sitting outside the police lines
the riot big hoards of people coming to
just get the rest of the city they had
it and we had to take a separate
direction get out so it is fully charged
fully energized more police units coming
in federal agents it is I would say just
getting started Oh oh my god all right
well thank you so much mr. Schaefer and
I don't know the name of your producer
there what's the name of your Austin
Austin Holland thank you guys I
appreciate it and do me a favor though I
know you guys obviously want to get the
story but we are at a point as you said
this is this is a different level and I
want to make I don't want to make sure
I'm not your dad but I would like to
know that you guys are safe because the
last thing I want to see is somebody
else beaten within an inch of their life
here at these protests and I know it's
tough for me to say because we rely on
you but I also don't want to see you
guys hurt so so do keep us posted I
really appreciate you guys calling in
see even our unanticipated correspondent
yeah are better than this than this
enjoyed this video subscribe or hit the
notification bell because that lets your
mobile device you people still say cell
I don't think they say but no one says
LTE we should say cellular but we don't
say LTE but then what was there was
there was roaming do we still have
roaming I think we still have roaming if
you're watching this on mobile I've
wasted a ton of your and you're likely
driving you're probably dead
everybody's looking back now and the
road is just there are some lights and
sirens going off maybe there's like a
pair of slacks in your the grille of
your car next to the Rudolph nose that
you put in for some holiday festivity
only now it's covered in someone else's
blood so hit the notification bell join
mug Club bit lighter with crater comm
slash mug club because that's how we
support this we don't actually make any
money off of YouTube and we do a full
dailies like 80% more content and you
know what I hope that your blood type is
o-negative